und wir schauen direkt nach schloss
meseberg tag 2 der klausurtagung der
bundesregierung und wir erwarten jetzt
die ergebnisse und werden den
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hören aber
auch robert habeck wird sprechen und
christian lindner
ergeben
meine damen und herren die
kabinettsklausur die wir gestern heute
hier in meseberg hatten war erfolgreich
wir haben sehr sorgfältig mit der andere
diskutierte über all die fragen ganz
besonders diejenigen die mit der
zeitenwende verbunden sind die aus dem
krieg russlands gegen die ukraine
herrührt wir haben intensiv diskutiert
über die fragen der politischen
konsequenzen insbesondere was die
zusammenarbeit in europa betrifft
gestern hat mir ein sehr gutes gespräch
mit den ministerpräsidenten von finnland
und schweden über die fragen die sich
aus dieser veränderten welt lage und der
veränderten lage in europa für uns alle
ergeben eins ist klar europa muss enger
zusammenwachsen wir brauchen ein starkes
souveränes europa aber auch das
transatlantische bündnis die
zusammenarbeit in der nato hat eine ganz
neue bedeutung für unsere sicherheit
gewonnen und wir wollen alles dazu
beitragen dass diese sicherheit auch
gemeinsam gewonnen werden kann unser
beitrag ist die enge kooperation mit
unseren partnern unser beitrag ist auch
ein sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
mit dem wir sicherstellen wollen dass
die bundeswehr gut ausgestattet sein
kann in den nächsten jahren mit dem
beschluss verbunden ist auch die absicht
dass wir zwei prozent unserer
wirtschaftsleistung für die bundeswehr
künftig aufwenden eine wichtiger beitrag
deutschlands den übrigens so ähnlich
viele andere regierungen dann auch
leisten werden wir haben gestern von
unseren skandinavischen kollegen gehört
was wir von vielen anderen wissen dass
sie dieser deutschen entscheidung in
ihren eigenen bewertungen entscheidungen
auch gefolgt sind und weiter folgen
werden und das für sich selber genauso
sehen klar ist auch dass aus dieser
veränderung feucht
dass putin sich vollständig verrechnet
hat mit seinem brutalen angriffs krieg
gegen die ukraine denn wasser bekommt
ist eine stärkere nato ist die stärkere
organisation von sicherheit auch an den
östlichen staaten des nato gebietes was
er bekommen hat ist eine einige
europäische union und viele gemeinsam
handelnde staaten in der welt
demokratien die organisiert haben das
mit einem umfassenden sanktionspaket
russland
zu verstehen bekommt dass es diesen
krieg beenden soll ein sanktionspaket
dass die wirtschaftlichen
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten russlands
erheblich
beeinträchtigen ein schafft die dafür
gesorgt hat dass die ukraine militärisch
unterstützt wird mit rüstungsgütern die
in die ukraine geliefert werden und viel
finanzieller hilfe auch deutschland
beteiligt sich daran unverändert und
wird das auch weiter tun mit immer den
entscheidungen jeweils zu der zeit
richtig und angemessen sind das hat
unsere diskussion bestimmt genauso wie
dann vertieft die frage welche
konsequenzen das auch für unser eigenes
land hat wir wissen dass es unglaublich
viele menschen gibt die wegen dieses
krieges die ukraine verlassen haben
millionen sind es mittlerweile die in
der ukraine auf der flucht sind aber an
auch viele millionen die die ukraine
verlassen haben viele davon sind
zunächst in den östlichen staaten
europas angekommen ganz besonders in
polen das eine große leistung an dieser
stelle
zustande bringt aber eben auch in
deutschland wir wissen dass es viele
hunderttausend sind die sich bisher
schon hier gemeldet haben und unserem
ausländerzentralregister
registriert werden konnten viele
hunderttausend und es ist auch noch mehr
werden können deshalb haben wir uns mit
den ländern verständigt über eine
gemeinsame arbeit an dieser frage und
eine der ganz großen aufgaben die wir zu
bewältigen haben ist wie kriegen wir das
hin dass es perspektiven gibt für
diejenigen die länger bleiben wollen und
das in der zeit hinter diejenigen die
bald wieder gehen wollen sich hier
aufhalten sie eine gute möglichkeit
haben für sich und ihre kinder auch der
beruflichen integration
deshalb gehört zu den dingen die wir uns
vorgenommen haben die jetzt
gesetzgeberisch auf den weg gebracht
sind der wechsel in die sicherungs
strukturen der jobcenter und der
bundesagentur für arbeit und das trägt
dazu bei dass in dem richtigen system
die hilfe und unterstützung für eine
gute integration in deutschland
gewährleistet werden kann ein großer
vorgang der jetzt gesetzgeberisch
bewältigt werden muss diese frage wie
die arbeitsmarkt integration gelingt die
frage wie die integration gelingt in die
kinderbetreuung in die schulen die frage
wie die integration gelingt in das
system unserer wissenschaftlichen
einrichtungen und der universitäten hat
uns intensiv beschäftigt und wir haben
das vertieft diskutiert und unsere
arbeit dabei koordiniert auch das war
wichtig dass wir dafür genügend zeit
hatten dann ist es klar dass die
veränderungen denen wir gegenwärtig
ausgesetzt sind wegen der neuen
rahmenbedingungen für die globalisierung
wegen der anforderungen die sich aus der
kurve 19 pandemie ergeben und war auch
den vielen konjunkturprogramm die über
auf der welt auf den weg gebracht worden
sind wegen jetzt das ukraine krieges
aber auch wegen der notwendigen
transformation unserer volkswirtschaft
dass diese veränderung auch global
wirtschaftliche folgen haben werden die
wir verstehen müssen als land das
wahrscheinlich zu den am meisten in der
weltwirtschaft vernetzten gehört
vielleicht sind wir sogar das land mit
der größten vernetzungen die
weltwirtschaft als exporteure und
importeure von gütern und
dienstleistungen das wollen wir bleiben
mit unserem ganz starken schwerpunkt auf
industrieller produktion und das zu
organisieren und gleichzeitig
sicherzustellen dass wir in kurzer zeit
klimaneutral wirtschaften können das ist
die herausforderung vor der wir stehen
mit der wir uns dann beschäftigt haben
im gespräch mit zwei wissenschaftlern
die das hier beeindruckend mit uns
diskutiert haben alle haben diese
diskussion persönlich als bereicherung
empfunden aber auch als orientierung für
die vielen einzelfragen die wir jeden
tag zu lösen haben wie sehr das dann der
fall ist dass uns die fragen dieses
krieges und der konsequenzen bewegen hat
dann auch die heutige kabinettssitzung
wieder gezeigt wir haben uns sehr
sorgfältig beschäftigt mit nach kräften
die möglicherweise auch russland je her
kommen die bisher zusammengearbeitet
haben mit unternehmen in deutschland wir
haben uns mit der globalen
ernährungskrise beschäftigt die aus der
situation des ukraine krieges folgt wir
wissen alle dass die ukraine und aus
russland große exportländer für weizen
und sind und dass die
ernährungssicherheit viele länder in der
welt davon abhängt dass das auch weiter
gelingt deshalb können wir die länder
die jetzt bedroht sind mit
ernährungskrisen nicht alleine lassen
und natürlich geht es weiter mit unseren
ganzen intensiven gesetzgebungsvorhaben
die jetzt notwendig sind damit wir die
unabhängigkeit erreichen können die wir
anstreben von fossilen importen aus
russland
dazu gehört zum beispiel das lg lg
beschleunigungsgesetz dass wir jetzt im
detail miteinander noch einmal
diskutiert haben und wo wir dann bis zum
montag auch eine endgültige
beschlussfassung im kabinett zustande
bringen werden damit das in den
fraktionen beraten werden kann und noch
vor der sommerpause gesetz werden kann
das gleiche gilt für das aus der
gemeinsamen arbeit gegen all die
begünstigten des putin regimes
notwendige sanktions durchsetzungs
gesetz wo wir jetzt auch die
gesetzgeberischen kriterien dafür
verändern dass unsere task force die da
bereits unterwegs ist erfolgreich sein
kann also man sieht all diese themen
hängen eng miteinander zusammen und
gerade deshalb ist es richtig dass wir
als regierung und so intensiv damit hier
beschäftigt haben wir alle sind uns
menschlich esiea ich glaube das ist
etwas was diese koalition auszeichnet
dass hier eine gute kooperation statt
findet und diese klausur hat dann noch
einmal beigetragen dazu dass die schwere
arbeit die wir zu leisten haben und die
notwendig ist gerade in einer so
schweren zeit dass die auch gemeinsam
und solidarisch weiter vorangetrieben
werden kann zwei punkte möchte ich noch
sagen weil sie heute im kabinett
beschlüsse zur folge hatten zunächst
einmal die frage unseres zukunfts
zentrums für deutsche einheit und
europäische transformationen ein
beschluss für den ich mich schon in
früherer tätigkeit sehr eingesetzt habe
er aus den
beschäftigung mit der
deutschen einheit erwachsen ist und den
empfehlungen der kommission der letzten
legislaturperiode dieses zukunftszentrum
wollen wir unbedingt jetzt auf den weg
bringen und deshalb sind die dazu
notwendigen eckpunkte heute im kabinett
beschlossen worden damit der prozess
aufgesetzt werden kann in dem sich
städte und gemeinden in ostdeutschland
als ort für dieses zukunftszentrum
bewerben können und wir die konzeption
weiter vorantreiben können und natürlich
gerade jetzt wo wieder krieg in europa
ist ist es ganz besonders wichtig dass
die
kulturstaatsministerin heute uns den
realisierungs vorschlag für ein
dokumentationszentrum zweiter weltkrieg
und deutsche besatzung herrschaft in
europa vorgestellt
in dem sinne bin ich noch mal für die
zusammenarbeit die diese klausur mit
sich gebracht hat und freue mich auf das
was wir miteinander voranbringen kann
ja schon morgens der damen und herren
dann lassen sie mich nahtlos an den
worten des bundeskanzlers anknüpfen vor
fünf monaten haben wir als regierung ein
start hingelegt der getragen war von
einer atmosphäre des aufbruchs das model
war mehr fortschritt wagen und dann kam
die korona krise noch mal voll zurück
dann begann der krieg und der krieg ist
natürlich neben all dem väterlichen was
in der ukraine passiert auf eine extreme
herausforderung für deutschland für die
alliierten für die partner in europa
auch natürlich für uns und da muss man
jetzt nicht drüber hinweg reden so
aufbruchs mäßig war die stimmung jetzt
nicht sondern das war eine phase von
also den letzten monaten sondern es war
eine phase von höchster konzentration
und auch einen tiefen bewusst sein dass
wir gerade einen historischen moment
erleben und wie den bestehen müssen als
regierung als deutschland und in europa
die kabinettssitzungen davor die
gespräche die wir in den
koalitionsausschuss 'nen haben sie waren
immer sehr fokussiert sie waren die zeit
war hat nie gereicht und wirklich mal
ein gedanken frei zu formulieren
alles musste sofort immer übersetzt
werden man ist rein gestürmt mann ist
raus gestürmt man hat dann weiterhin
sein ministerium gearbeitet
insofern war es gut und ich würde fast
sagen auch wichtig dass wir jetzt mal
ein bisschen mehr zeit haben wieder das
große bild zu malen da anzuknüpfen wo
wir waren und so war es tatsächlich
natürlich war auch diese
klausurtagung geprägt von der situation
in der wir uns befinden von der großen
ernsthaftigkeit von dem klaren
bewusstsein dass jede kleinste
entscheidung große auswirkungen haben
kann und trotzdem hatten wir ein
bisschen mehr zeit fragen zu stellen
nachzudenken den horizont mal wieder in
den blick zu nehmen und das hat diese
klausur besonders gemacht ich will nicht
sagen dass die leichtigkeit des
aufbruchs zurückgekommen ist aber die
das anknüpfen an der dynamik und auch an
der verbindlichkeit die wir miteinander
hatten das hat diesen diese wie viel
warnt 36 stunden tatsächlich zu
besonderen gemacht
das hat sich dann auch in den debatten
widergespiegelt und der bundeskanzler
hat ein paar punkte angesprochen ich
will noch mal kurz aufgreifen denn sie
werden alle nur funktionieren wenn die
regierung gut kooperiert und diese
kooperation die solidarität miteinander
und der wille und da muss man ja auch
nicht darüber hinwegsehen dass partner
die aus unterschiedlichen erfahrungen
und vielleicht parteipolitischen
voreinstellungen kommen jetzt leistung
bringen müssen der hat diese tage
geprägt
wir haben heute das
lng planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz noch
einmal beraten das ist ein gesetz das
die deutschen genehmigungs standards auf
das minimum das europäisch notwendig ist
runter kürzt so dass die genehmigung die
dann da die länder für die lng terminals
und die infrastruktur zu erteilen haben
in wenigen wochen zu erteilen sind nicht
in monaten nicht in jahren sondern wie
in wenigen wochen dieses gesetz konnte
nur in den letzten wochen erarbeitet
werden weil das umweltministerium und
das justizministerium und alle anderen
häuser wahnsinnig gut beigetragen haben
niemand hat an seiner eigenen ressorts
und die eigene rückversicherung bei den
eigenen milieus gedacht sondern nur die
aufgabe gesehen und geholfen sonst wäre
das nicht gegangen deswegen noch mal
jetzt an der stelle der herzliche dank
an das umweltministerium und steffi
lemke und marco buschmann und das
justizministerium
zweiten punkt den der bundeskanzler
angesprochen hat es kommt viele
geflüchtete aus der ukraine zu uns und
die gut zu versorgen und dazu bringen
aber auch in den arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren
das ist natürlich die aufgabe der stunde
wir bieten aber auch denjenigen
einen arbeitsplatz an die aus russland
fliehen oder schon geflohen sind sie
also vor dem putin regime das land
verlassen haben oder nicht mehr in das
land zurück wollen also diejenigen die
aus russland zu uns kommen und wollen
sie auch bewusst ansprechen wie können
sie gut gebrauchen in deutschland das zu
sagen heißt natürlich dass eine menge
von ressourcen parieren müssen damit das
auch schnell gelingt das
arbeitsministerium allen voran dass die
hürden für die beschäftigung und die
anerkennung von berufsabschlüssen
herabsenken muss das auswärtige amt dass
die erteilung von einreisevisa
schnell durchführen muss das
innenministerium das gucken muss dass
nicht die falschen zu uns kommen und wir
uns auf einmal hier laut das spiel ohne
ans land holen das
wirtschaftsministerium das in der
kooperation mit den wirtschaftsverbänden
dafür sorgen muss dass die leute auch in
arbeit finden keiner kann es alleine
machen nur wenn wir uns gegenseitig
unterstützen und helfen gelingt es
drittes beispiel ein thema das
vielleicht noch zu oberflächlich medial
gehandelt wird oder flottes angesprochen
der kollege cem özdemir hat das noch mal
ausgeführt die nahrungsmittelknappheit
wird die welt hart treffen und zwar
teile der welt die sowieso schon
politisch unruhig sind und die geht es
unserer ansicht nach nicht nur darum
dass leute nicht hungern sollen das ist
natürlich schon aufgabe genug menschen
nicht verhungern zu lassen in dieser
situation sondern das über die
nahrungsmittelversorgung natürlich auch
politische stabilität gewährt wird bzw
ein unterbleiben von genug
kalorienzufuhr
möglicherweise zu politischer
instabilität in
angespannten politischen lagen oder in
unsicheren regionen führt heißt wer muss
kooperieren das außen das
außenministerium das
landwirtschaftsministerium das
entwicklungshilfeministerium und das
kanzleramt ist sowieso immer mit dabei
also insofern zeigen alle bereiche was
wir als regierung leisten müssen wenn
wir uns in unseren ressorts verschanzen
und sagen hauptsache ich stehe gut da
und ich lass' ich mal ein bisschen
rumzappeln dann wird das alles nichts
werden und das hat die kabinettssitzung
heute gezeigt vor allem aber haben das
die letzten stunden hier gezeigt dass
dieser wille da ist dass wir uns
unterstützen und als eine regierung
helfen und agieren und
vielleicht war das auch ein
motivationsschub einfach weiter zu
machen den wir alle gut gebrauchen
konnten nicht dass wir nicht motiviert
werden aber es hat einfach noch mal ein
team gedanken ohne dass er ausgesprochen
wurde unterstrichen und dafür kann ich
mir danke sagen die regierung arbeitet
sehr gut zusammen
ja es war eine sehr erfolgreiche
klausurtagung des bundeskabinetts sie
war im übrigen auch net in einer
konzentrierten teilweise auch gelösten
stimmung
wir haben uns mit schwer- und fragen
beschäftigt aber das heißt nicht dass
auch
gelegentlich herzlich miteinander
gelacht worden ist das gehört ja auch in
schwierigen zeiten dazu und ist auch
ausdruck sehr partnerschaftlichen art
wie wir die dinge angehen sagt dem wir
ins amt gekommen sind ist die arbeit der
bundesregierung
bestimmt gewesen vom management
unterschiedlicher krisen ist nicht nur
allein eine pandemie zu bewältigen
gewesen sondern wir haben auch noch
krieg in europa
das bestimmt das politische
tagesgeschäft stärker als die
ursprünglich erhofft hatten als wir alle
es uns gewünscht haben ganz konkret
jetzt in
meinem bereich konnte ich heute
berichten über die
weiteren schritte in richtung auf das
sanktions durchsetzungs gesetz gibt ja
die gemeinsame task force des
wirtschafts und finanzministeriums und
diese taskforce hatten wir gebeten
eckpunkte aufzuschreiben wo es defizite
gibt bei der ermittlung wirtschaftlich
begünstigte die auf sanktionslisten
stehen haben wir einige vorschläge
zusammengefügt aber es ist auch ein
neues instrument im gespräch dass wir
innerhalb des kabinetts
jetzt prüfen
wir prüfen ob
diejenigen die auf sanktionslisten sind
gesetzlich verpflichtet werden können
ihre vermögensgegenstände in deutschland
offen zu legen diese gesetzliche
verpflichtung von gelisteten personen
wäre dann auch bewährt mit bußgeld
beziehungsweise strafrechtlich das wäre
ein ganz neues instrument um die
durchsetzung bestehender sanktionen
gegen natürliche personen gegen
juristische personen um das
schlagkräftiger zu machen wir sind jetzt
in der schlussphase der prüfung
innerhalb der bundesregierung
wir wollen dann in einem umlauf
verfahren bis zum kommenden montag den
gesetzentwurf in der form einer
formulierungshilfe beschließen so dass
die bundestagsfraktion diese
formulierungshilfe am dienstag
bearbeiten können bei dieser
klausurtagung haben wir aber auch jetzt
einen schritt unternommen mal über die
krise hinaus langfristig strategisch auf
die neue lage zu schauen der ukraine
krieg verändert die sicherheitssituation
in europa ist eine sicherheitspolitische
zeitenwende er markiert aber auch eine
ökonomische zeitenwende die bedingungen
des geschäftsmodells deutschland mit dem
wir sehr erfolgreich gewesen sind
verändern sich robert habe kann jeden
tag darüber berichten wie sich die
energieversorgung unseres landes
verändert und übrigens dann auch die
fragen der preise und der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit wenn wir uns aus
anderen quellen auch unter anderen
bedingungen mit anderen konditionen
versorgen müssen also das
geschäftsmodell deutschland verändert
sich das makroökonomische umfeld hat
sich deutlich verändert das zeigen die
reduzierten
wachstumsprognosen und die erhöhten
inflationszahlen und weiter bestehenden
risiken wir haben einen offenen
austausch begonnen über all das was
getan werden muss die wirtschaftliche
wachstum und fortschritt perspektive
unseres landes zu stärken
knappheiten zu überwinden fachkräfte
energie
rohstoffe all das was uns bremst beim
aufbau von produktivität und
zusätzlichen produktionskapazitäten was
zu mehr wirtschaftlicher prosperität am
ende führen kann und wir haben auf der
anderen seite natürlich auch sehr offen
gesprochen über die inflations situation
und lässt nicht kalt wenn die menschen
durch die preise belastet werden wir
haben zwei große sanktionspaket ja
bereits geschnürt wir wollen dass diese
sanktion dass diese entlastungspaket
karton dass diese entlastungspaket jetzt
auch wirken dass sie bald gesetzeskraft
bekommen die menschen nicht alleine
gelassen werden und wir hoffen damit
schon einen wesentlichen beitrag
geleistet zu haben um diesem jahr dem
den menschen den alltag zu erleichtern
wir werden auch fragen der finanzpolitik
in deutschland und europa justieren
müssen angesichts der
inflationszahlen da ist es notwendig
dass wir mit den veränderten
finanziellen möglichkeiten des staates
sehr sorgsam umgehen um nicht selbst
zusätzlich etwa durch subventionen die
preise anzutreiben oder auch die
handlungsmöglichkeiten der europäischen
zentralbank zu beschneiden indem nämlich
die mitglieder der währungsunion immer
stärker in verschuldungssituation
geraten nachdem ja durch die pandemie
ohnehin die verschuldungsquoten höher
sind also es war nicht nur krisen
management dass uns hier beschäftigt hat
sondern wir haben auch schon darüber
hinaus geschaut auf all das was in
veränderte lage an ökonomischen
herausforderungen auf dieses land
zukommt ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir
auch zu
modifizierten innovativen antworten
kommen am neue ideen miteinander
entwickelt die wir jetzt nach und nach
konkretisieren werden mit hohem tempo
und hoher ambitionen
als erstes habe ich fragen denn michael
fischer von dpa
vielen dank ich hätte zwei fragen zum
thema ukraine herr minister habe die
eu-kommission hat ja heute ihr sechstes
sanktionspaket gegen russland
vorgestellt das enthält ein öl-embargo
können sie vielleicht erklären dass
dieses embargo für deutschland bedeuten
wird vor allen dingen für die deutschen
verbraucher und der bundeskanzler
der oppositionsführer friedrich mehr als
hat gestern kiew besucht mich würde
interessieren wie sie diese reise
bewährten glauben sie dass sie zur
verbesserung der deutsch ukrainischen
beziehungen beiträgt und fühlen sie sich
vielleicht dadurch animiert
dann doch bald selbst nach kiew zu
reisen
der vorschlag der europäischen
kommission kommt nicht komplett
unerwartet
wir sind ja an den vorgesprächen
intensiv beteiligt gewesen es gab
energieministerrat oder konferenz in
sonderkonferenz in brüssel vor ein paar
tagen
die übergangsfrist ist so ausreichend
lang dass wir alle vorkehrungen treffen
können um alternativen für russisches öl
in deutschland zu schaffen
vorkehrungen treffen heißt nicht dass
sie sich gleich realisieren das heißt
und auch keine neue nachricht ich habe
ein paar mal gesagt wir können natürlich
nicht in dieser situation garantieren
dass es nicht stockend wird vor allem
regional stockend wird die raffinerie
schwedt das ist ja dass die
herausforderung
raffiniert russisches öl die gehört
rosneft dieses konglomerat muss man
politisch lösen damit die arbeit
entsteht und das ist das ziel der
bundesregierung ich habe die proteste
der deutschen entsteht natürlich gesehen
dass die klare aussage der
bundesregierung ist dass der standort
erhalten bleiben soll dass wir dort eine
zukunftsfähige industrie aufbauen wollen
dass das embargo gegen russisches öl
nicht dazu führt dass in der region die
lichter ausgehen ganz im gegenteil wir
werden und das ist ja die arbeit der
letzten wochen und monate gewesen dafür
sorge tragen dass wir eine andere
versorgung auch von öl für den
industriestandort
sicherstellen können dass das ganze dann
umgesetzt werden muss und das ist da
vielleicht gewissen stockungen geben
kann das ist auch schon ein paar mal
gesagt worden aber das ist etwas anderes
als dass wir das öl embargo als nation
nicht tragen können und was die preise
angeht so ist die frist ja sehr lang so
dass ich nur in die glaskugel gucken
könnte wenn man jetzt über reaktionen an
den börsen spekulieren würde
möglicherweise sind die auch schon
eingepreist die märkte reagieren da ganz
vorausschauend aber natürlich können die
preise auch deutlich nach oben gehen bei
einer frist von 180 tagen allerdings
werden sie hoch und runter gehen und
dann wird man jeweils die konkrete
situation sich anschauen müssen also das
ist das werk und spekulationen an der
stelle eine verknappung von rohöl auf
dem weltmarkt führt natürlich erst
einmal prinzipiell zu höheren preisen
inwieweit spekulationsgewinne drin sind
die auch wieder rausgehen ist heute
nicht zu beurteilen
in der tat sie wissen dass wir in
deutschland unterwegs sind uns
unabhängig zu machen von fossilen
importen aus russland im hinblick auf
die kohle sind die entscheidungen
gefallen und die arbeit der wirtschaft
findet zusammen mit uns intensiv statt
das auch zu realisieren wir haben auch
gesagt dass wir so schnell wie möglich
aus der abhängigkeit von ölimporten
herauskommen wollen haben uns da
begonnen darauf vorzubereiten du bist
schon vor dem kriegsausbruch weil wir
das als eine große herausforderung von
vornherein gesehen haben genauso wie die
gast frage und deshalb sind wir jetzt in
dieser situation mit den vorschlägen der
europäischen kommission
anders aufgestellt als wenn das alles
nicht schon längst unterwegs wäre und
sich die unternehmen und wir in
deutschland gedanken darüber machen wie
man mit einer solchen situation umgehen
kann die er im übrigen auch
immer entstehen kann weil nichts
geliefert wird das muss man ja auch
ausdrücklich dazu sagen ein thema das
uns ja auch nicht das wäre ja auch nicht
unbeachtet lassen können deshalb sind
wir also vorbereitet und diskutieren und
das will ich hier noch mal
unterstreichen
für uns alle ist wichtig dass wir bei
allen beschlüssen die jetzt gefasst
werden gleichzeitig absolute klarheit
haben dass wir die handlungs dimensionen
nutzen können die wir brauchen um neuner
und schwert zu unterstützen und
sicherzustellen dass die beschäftigten
dort und die tätigkeit dort eine
ökonomische perspektive hat die
funktioniert
im übrigen was ihre frage betrifft will
ich gerne noch mal unterstreichen dass
sich auch an anderer stelle gesagt habe
es ist ein problem dass der präsident
der bundesrepublik deutschland
ausgeladen wurde und das steht im raum
das steht aber nicht dass stand jetzt
mit mir darüber gesprochen hat aber
seine reise nicht entgegen und wir haben
uns darüber unterhalten und werden uns
auch nach seiner rückkehr weiter
unterhalten
andreas rinke von reuters als nächstes
dankeschön für bundeskanzler noch mal
eine nachfrage zu dem thema öl embargo
die eu-kommission hat ja
übergangsfristen für die slowakei und
ungarn vorgeschlagen sehen sie darin
eigentlich einen gefährlichen
präzedenzfall weil das ja jetzt zum
ersten mal ist dass innerhalb eines
sanktionspaket
ausnahmeregelungen für zwei zumindestens
der 27 eu mitglieder vorgesehen sind
herbert auch eine nachfrage dazu sie
hatten ja mal vorgeschlagen dass die
windfall profits die durch die
steigenden öl und gaspreise anfallen
abgeschöpft werden möglicherweise für
ukraine hilfen ist dass auch diskutiert
worden sind sie da weitergekommen und
herr lindner sie hatten das thema
inflation angesprochen und gestern abend
ja auch für einen zweitrunden effekt
sogar gewarnt würden sie dafür plädieren
dass die tarifpartner bei den
tarifverhandlungen zurückhaltend sein
sollten da
ganz klare aussage es ist von vornherein
unser gemeinsames konzept in europa
übrigens auch mit allen anderen
verbündeten dass wir bei den sanktionen
die wir absprechen vorbereiten und sie
wissen dass deutschland da eine
federführende rolle schon vor dem krieg
eingenommen hat jeweils zu entwickeln
und zu präzisieren dass wir sie so
ausgestalten dass die auswirkung bei uns
nicht schlimmer sind als bei dem land
das wir treffen wollen wegen seines
furchtbaren krieges gegen die ukraine
und deshalb ist es kein
gefährlicher präzedenzfall wie sie
formuliert haben sondern eigentlich eine
pragmatische fortsetzung der politik die
wir bisher alle gemeinsam vorgenommen
haben dass wir immer darauf achten dass
das auch für alle konkret möglich ist
was man von ihnen verlangt und ich
glaube das wird unser verhalten in der
zukunft prägen wie es das in der
vergangenheit getan hat ich möchte das
unterstreichen wir haben für uns in
anspruch genommen als der krieg ausbrach
dass wir politisch so vorgehen wollen
dass wir erst die schritte vorbereiten
bevor wir sie gehen statt die schritte
zu gehen und zu sagen gott was haben wir
denn da gemacht wir haben hart dafür
gearbeitet das war ja ein thema von
vielen diskussionen und gab ja auch
widerstand dagegen stimmen dagegen wir
haben hart dafür gearbeitet dass das
jetzt so unmöglich ist und
können jetzt diese schritte mit gehen
wenn andere länder entweder nicht so
hart dafür gearbeitet haben oder andere
abhängigkeiten haben dann ist letzteres
in ordnung das was für uns in anspruch
genommen haben gilt natürlich auch für
andere länder jetzt also auch nichts
wenn die ökonomien zusammenbrechen ich
erwarte aber natürlich auch dass andere
länder ebenfalls ihre bemühungen
intensivieren und zwar im europäischen
verbund in der solidarität der
europäischen staaten die unabhängigkeit
dann zu schaffen also insofern stimmig
olaf scholz natürlich zu dass das kein
präzedenzfall ist sondern eine umsetzung
der logik die wir in deutschland quasi
auch
vorgegeben oder eingeführt brachte wir
uns verhalten haben
die abschöpfung von über gewinn ist
finde ich noch immer ein wichtiges thema
und ist auf der agenda das ist nicht
trivial das auf einzelne sektoren zu
beschränken weil das steuerrecht im
grunde da
neutral ist ich bin jetzt kein großer
kenner aber ich nehme an auch da sind
die preise nach oben gegangen und wenn
die ölfirmen gegen die charta firmen
klagen und sagen dass der staatliche
willkür und dann ist es weg dann ist es
auch nicht gut das heißt es wird noch an
konzepten gearbeitet das gleiche gilt
für die besteht für die rituelle die auf
importe gelegt werden und auch für das
camping also dass man einkauf kartells
bildet und sagt über einem bestimmten
preis kauft man nicht ein aber die dinge
sind eben in der konkretion in der
politischen umsetzung in der regel
komplizierter
weil die natürlich recht schaffen und
auch in der rechtsnormen argumentiert
werden müssen als es so manch mal flott
daher gesagt ist deswegen finde ich alle
drei themen über gewinnbesteuerung zölle
und camping sind auf der tagesordnung
aber sie sehen aus dem vorschlag der
europäischen kommission dass man noch
nicht die lösung gefunden hat das alles
jetzt sofort umzusetzen
die bundesregierung hat ja
sogar die statements von scholz habeck
und lindner bei der klausurtagung in
meseberg und bei uns weiterhin im studio
bild politik chef jan schäfer ja war für
mich eine überraschung jetzt dabei also
zwei dinge glaube ich kann man jetzt aus
der pressekonferenz mitnehmen ist es
ernst gearbeitet worden das haben alle
drei minister und der kanzlerin zwei
minister unter kanzler noch mal betont
interessant war und darüber hatten wir
ja im vorfeld der pressekonferenz schon
geredet das ist ja hinter den kulissen
doch ziemlich geknirscht hat und umso
bemerkenswerter dass gerade robert
habeck immer wieder hervorgehoben hat
wie groß doch und wie gut dieser
teamgeist sein wie wichtig dieses
treffen gewesen ist das haben das war
sehr auffällig und da ist es mutmaßlich
zu einer offenen sehr offenen aussprache
gekommen gerade zwischen christian
lindner und ihnen denn die beiden
beharken sich beim thema steuerfragen
immer wieder das ist quasi auch der
zweite punkt die fdp hat ja im
koalitionsvertrag durchgesetzt dass es
keine steuererhöhungen geben wird und
der interne wutausbruch von christian
lindner der bezog sich gerade auf immer
neue forderungen der grünen neue steuern
einzuführen oder eben auch zu erhöhen
und da war dieses thema übergewicht
steuer dass die grünen-parteichefin
ricarda lang zu beginn der woche im jahr
eingeführt und genau darauf ist aber
robert habe gerade eben wieder
eingegangen hat gesagt ja also da wird
noch an einem konzept gearbeitet wie man
diese über gewinnsteuern nun einführen
könnte das kann nicht auf die zustimmung
von christian lindner getroffen haben
das heißt das was wir da auch gesehen
haben und was uns gesagt wurde diese
große harmonie und dieser teamgeist der
da offenbar jetzt den geist von meseberg
ausgemacht hat der ist eigentlich direkt
in der pressekonferenz danach
wieder auf die prüfung gestellt worden
schade dass wir in dem moment wo es
gesagt hat nicht nur mal die gegend
kamera hatten auf christian in das
gesicht hätte wahrscheinlich dann bände
gesprochen jan schäfer dankeschön für
deine ganz aktuelle einschätzung hierher
uns